I didn't give up this show cuz it was
the show I loved the least I gave up
this show because it was the show that
demanded the most and I couldn't chase
my dreams and also make a day-in day-out
you know eleven and a half months out of
the year talk-show they just were
incompatible I think when I announced
that I was leaving that was so sad like
I could I cried so much like you know
I'm showing off the show then that I and
then I had some time to process it but
it was so fun like it was last day of
school fun it was like you know we went
to Disneyland didn't go to class fun the
videos are great these women are
incredible people and you know some you
know you have people you don't think you
deserve their friendship like I really
feel very blessed to know them like they
really love you
god I don't even I said after one of the
seconds of the show guys like I don't
really know how to say how I feel right
now like but know that what you said is
gonna be in my heart for the rest of my
life but you you really touched me in a
way that it's gonna affect everything
that I do from this point forward for
women that I admire this much for them
to say those kinds of things I mean it's
just it's you know and how much will you
miss this walking out here the fans the
interaction because people don't realize
you really interact with everybody here
all day long while you're out on the
stage
this Monday was it was this muddy we
walked out and I just thought oh god I'm
gonna miss this moment because there's
this moment right before this where
we're kind of chatting and gossiping I
love your dress what are you doing this
weekend oh my god I got this funny email
right before we walk out here in that
the few seconds before we're live and
then we all walk out and we're holding
hands or laughing or someone stumbled or
whatever and that beat where we are team
are the Avengers have assembled those
few seconds are so precious and magical
and I know I already know I'm gonna miss
that
really deeply you talked about the fans
and how they make this show and that you
guys really talk more about issues that
face you every day and not world topics
and how that has changed the way that
people view talk television now I mean I
think the reason why people connect with
this show is because we connect with
them because we're trying to be as open
and as honest and as truthful as we can
here and what we don't care about
winning that's not our goal out there
our goal is to tell the truth and I
think you can see authenticity and you
can connect without the insisting when
it happens and I think a lot of other
shows it's about making your point it's
about winning the argument it's about
being the leader of the debate our point
is to connect and that that authenticity
that truthfulness that we're really
trying to get you on the show which is
sometimes very difficult and very
painful for all of us and it's why this
show works and it's what's bonded us
because as authentic as we are out there
we're a hundred times more authentic and
unguarded one more off camera
[Music]